hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
longest common subsequence a dynamic
programming problem
and this is pretty much one of the most
popular dynamic programming problems so
we are given
two strings text 1 and text 2
and we just want to return the length of
the longest
common subsequence between these
two strings and you might remember from
my last video where we
learned basically what a sub sequence is
it's basically
uh you take a string right like this
string a b c d e
and you just you know you choose a few
characters from it
while you maintain the order so one sub
sequence from this string could be a b
right you take the first two characters
from and you can take any characters you
can choose to remove any characters you
can do whatever you want
and so we're looking for the longest
common subsequence
so a subsequence that is in both
of the strings so in this example we
have two strings right a b
c d e and a c e so what is the longest
common subsequence between these well
when you take a look at the first string
you see that hey they both have an a
right they both have an a in the first
spot so that's good
so now let's look at the second
character b and c
well this has a b but the second string
does not have a b
but the second string does have a c and
we also have a c over here
but the second string does not have a d
right so we can't include the d from the
first string but then we see the last
character is an e the last character and
the other string is also an e so
we get the longest common subsequence to
just be
the original second string right ace
because ace
can be found in the first string all we
have to do is remove
a couple characters right remove the b
and remove the d
then we get a subsequence that matches
the second string so the length of the
longest common subsequence
is three so how can we solve this
problem well as i mentioned dynamic
programming
is the most efficient way to solve this
problem but before we even get into the
dynamic programming solution
which is going to be a two dimensional
before we get into that let's just
notice one thing
do you so let's say these are our two
strings right string one and string two
does it at least make sense to you that
okay
like we would want to start let's say at
the beginning of both strings right like
we're looking for the longest common sub
sequence
it might just be that both of the
strings are actually equal right that
could be a possible way so let's
look at the first character in each
string and in this case
they match each other right they're the
same character
so does it at least make sense to you
that if
both of the characters match each other
right the first characters
that the longest common subsequence then
we can break it into a sub problem right
now
the new problem we're looking at is
finding the longest common subsequence
between the remainder of both strings
right
plus one plus one
because we see that the first two
characters
are equal right that's where our one
comes from right
because we know that the longest common
subsequence is at least
going to be one because we found a
matching
pair of characters right and then we
have a
sub problem right and you you might know
that
that's what dynamic programming is all
about finding the
sub problem now what if this character
was a b right and this is an
a so clearly they're not the same
character what would we do
then well we can't do what we just did
we can't add one and then find
the longest common subsequence between
uh the
the remainder of the two strings we
can't do that but
but we can break it into a different sub
problem we can say well
it's possible that the longest common
subsequence could be between
these two strings right or it could be
between
this string and this string so this is
just
a little bit of an explanation before i
show you the actual dynamic programming
solution right
basically what we found out is that
based on
comparing the first two characters
whether they're equal or not equal we
can break up
the problem into sub problems and then
solve those sub
problems so take a look what i just did
i took the
two input strings right string one and
string two
and i wrote them in a different way
right i
said that this is a two dimensional
dynamic programming problem
and you might know that a grid a 2d
grid like this is commonly used to solve
these types of dynamic programming
problems
so notice that for each character in
both
strings there's a square right a
position
a cell that we can put a value in we're
going to put a value in each of these
cells and so let's just start at the
beginning like we
did right so let's start at the first
characters right
what we're trying to do is for these
strings find the longest common
subsequence
between the entire strings right so what
we're going to do is put that value
right here that's what's going to be the
entire
longest common subsequence so we want to
compute the value that goes here but
what you're going to find is
to do that we need to solve some sub
problems
and then you know continue to do that
and then work our way back
up to this position so what do we notice
we let's look at these two characters
right they're
equal a and a right so okay so now we
want to find the value that goes here
how can we find that value
well like i mentioned right now we're
trying to solve a sub problem we want to
find the longest common subsequence
between these two substrings
right we don't have to check these a's
anymore because we know they match each
other
so now i want to find this new
sub problem right and so basically what
i'm saying is i'm going to go
here i'm i want to solve the sub problem
that goes here
so now we're here right we're comparing
this b
with this c we see that they're not
equal this time
right that means we're not going to be
going diagonally we're not going to look
at this sub problem we're going to look
at a different sub problem
since these characters do not equal each
other
we have to check two different sub
problems
it means that the longest common
subsurface between
these two substrings is going to be
found
in either of these two positions right
so let's look at this position first
with this position tells us we're trying
to find the longest common subsequence
between this string
and this string right so basically we're
not looking at this c
anymore right and this position tells us
that we're looking at the longest common
subsequence between this string
and this string so basically when we
remove this
b right and just by looking at it right
you can tell that this
is going to these two strings are going
to lead to a longest common subsequence
of one just by looking at it right
because you can see that this has one
character it's an e it only matches
this e so that's going to be a one but
when you look at
this string and this string right
corresponding to this position
we see that this has a ce this has a ce
so this is n
this is going to end up being a two but
let me actually solve
the rest of it a little bit so mainly
looking at these two strings right
in this position we see that the c's
match each other right so since
remember when the characters match each
other the first characters of both
strings match each other that's when we
go diagonally
and the reason we go diagonally is
because then we know we can look at the
remainder of both of the strings right
we
we know that this c matches this c so we
want to look diagonally we want to look
at these two substrings
so what's the longest common substring
between these two
okay so what are we gonna do let's
compare the first character right so
d and and e so these characters are
not equal so remember what we do when
the first characters are
not equal then we can't go diagonally so
what do we decide to do we go to the
right and we go
down and we take whatever the max of
these two
is and then put it in this value that's
what we're gonna do
so first let's check this right position
so what does this right position even
mean it means we're taking
this substring and finding the longest
common subsequence with this substring
but this is an
empty string so what's going to be in
this
cell remember this is actually out of
bounds
anyway right so what default value are
we gonna give ourselves if we go out of
bounds to the right
clearly the the longest come sub
sequence between a string and an empty
string like this
is gonna be zero right so really what
we're gonna initialize is we're gonna
say
every value in this column is going to
be 0.
similarly this is an empty substring if
it were to
if we were trying to find the lcs the
longest common subsequence between this
and an empty substring
we would also get zero so what we're
gonna do is put a zero
in these positions right that's just how
we're gonna initialize our 2d matrix
when we start the problem okay so
remember what we were doing we were at
this position we were going right and we
were going down trying to find the
maximum value well
clearly to the right we get a zero so
that's not the max
so let's go down okay now we're down so
what are we doing we're
finding the lcs between this substring
and
this substring well they're the exact
same right e matches
e okay great and remember when
characters match each other
that's when we look diagonally right so
we came down here and now we're looking
diagonally
clearly we get a zero here right so
zero plus one the reason we're doing a
plus
one here is because we found matching
characters when characters match
we add one because clearly the lcs
between these is going to at least be
one right at least one of these
characters matches
so now i'm basically gonna go here and
then take us
back along the path that we came from
and then show you what the solution
is so we had a one here right and so
from this position we went
down so since we were going down that
means that this character and this
character did not match each other so
what we're gonna do is just
take the one and put it up here right so
there's gonna be a one here
because the lcs between these two is one
but now we're gonna go back over here
diagonally right
diagonally means that this character
matched this character right
so we're going to take the value that we
got up here put it over here
and add one because remember these match
each other so we're adding one
that means we're going to end up putting
a two in this position
and now we're we we're going up right
we're going up
because that's where we came from and
remember when you go up that means the
characters did not match each other the
c
and the b don't match each other so
we're going to put a 2 here right we're
just taking this 2
and putting it over here and lastly
we're going back
here that's where we came from right
diagonally that means the characters
were matching each other so we can add
at least
one character so two plus one that's
going to be
three this is how we got the result
right so we got a
three meaning that the lcs between these
two strings is three right and that's
what we learned from the problem
explanation so right what we're going to
do is return
3 that's our result but you can see that
the way
i did it was basically intuitive right i
used this picture and basically solved
this problem by hand
using a little intuition and stuff right
but the way we're gonna have to solve
this with
code is gonna be brute force ish right
so it's dynamic programming
but what we're gonna have to do is for
every value
in this cell right so we are gonna
initialize these
zeros right but with this matrix right
this 2d matrix
we want the value that goes up here
right and to do that we have to compute
the value
that goes here that goes here that goes
here and basically for
all these and then finally we'll be able
to have the value that goes here which
is the result that we're going to return
and so basically what i'm saying is this
is going to be a bottom
up dynamic programming solution right
bottom
up meaning we're going gonna solve it in
reverse order we're gonna first
get every value we're gonna get the
value that goes here and then work our
way
up until we get to the result and you
might have noticed see i have an i that
tells us
the column i have a j that tells us
actually the column and the i tells us
what the row is
and so when we're working our way
starting at the bottom and then working
our way up
how are we going to determine what value
goes in each cell
basically what i went over earlier right
so we're going to look at the characters
and if they match each other what we're
going to do is say
one plus the value that's diagonal right
and we know
when we go out of bounds there's a zero
right there's an implicit
zero when we go out of bounds and we're
going to do that with
every single cell right so when you look
at these two we get an e
and a c right and when characters don't
match each other right
that's important what we're going to do
is we're going to look down
right we see a zero down here and we're
gonna go right
right to the right side and we see a one
here on the right side
and what we're gonna do is take the max
of those two values
and we see that the max is of course one
right one is bigger than zero and then
we're going to put that max value in
the cell so that's really it there are
two choices right
if the characters don't match each other
right in this case
or if their characters do match each
other in this case
right that's basically how we're going
to solve this problem it'll make a
little more sense when i show you the
code
so remember we're going to have a 2d
grid so i'm going to call that dp for
dynamic programming it's going to be a
2d grid and what i'm initially going to
do
is set it to all zeros right so and i'm
just gonna do a little bit of
uh python stuff so list comprehension in
python
so we're gonna go through every single
value
in the length of text two
plus one right plus one because we
we know that we need at least one more
column to have all the zeros in it
and so we're remember we're gonna put a
zero for every
value in that so length plus
one and we're going to have this row for
every value in the length
of string one so text one plus
one as well right so we're basically uh
if you're not familiar with python this
looks complicated but basically we're
getting a 2d grid of dimensions length 2
plus 1 times a length string 1 plus 1
and initializing it to
all zeros and then we're just going to
have a
nested loop and what we're going to do
is
iterate through this 2d grid in reverse
order
so in python you can do it like this and
basically what i'm doing is
starting at the bottom right of the
matrix and then working our way up
so this is how you do it in python
negative one negative one
and let's do the same thing for text
two and so remember so we're going
through every cell
in our 2d grid and remember there were
two conditions one condition
is if the characters in both strings
match each other so if text one of i
matches text two at position
j if they match each other we're going
to do something and if they
don't match each other we're going to do
something different so remember if they
do match each other then what we can say
is at this position
dp of i j because remember we're trying
to fill in
every single cell what we can do is then
just simply take one plus
the diagonal how do we find the diagonal
well we can say
i plus one and j plus one right that
gives us the diagonal
and remember we're adding one to it
because these characters match that
means we add a one
and if they don't match that's the else
case right so we're doing something
different here
we're going to put a different value for
dp of ij
and in this case what we're doing is
we're finding the maximum of
two values what are the two values the
value to the right
of this position so we can say dp of i j
plus one we can say that's the right
value and the
value below the bottom value so we can
say
i plus one and j for that
right so we're finding the maximum of
these two we're not adding one
we're not adding one because the
characters did not match each other
but basically literally these are the
two cases
we're just filling in a different value
depending on what the case
is and that's it so literally with these
two nested loops and with these two
conditions
we're filling in the entire dp matrix
and so once that matrix is filled in we
know that the result is going to be at
the top
left of that matrix so the dp the matrix
at index
0 0. that's going to have our result so
all we have to do now is return
the result and clearly you can see that
the
time complexity of this is the length of
the strings
multiplied by each other so if the
length of string one was n
and the length of string two was m we'd
just multiply them together so this
would be the time complexity
that's also the memory complexity
because we need extra memory for our 2d
dynamic programming grid oops i had just
one little bug i added
one to the inside of that function but i
needed to add one here
but other than that you can see that the
code
does work and it is pretty efficient
because the dynamic programming solution
is the most efficient for this problem
so i hope that this
was helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it supports the channel
a lot and i'll hopefully see you pretty
[Music]
soon